did you know the average billionaires  generation disappears within three  generations meaning Vanderbilts who's a  Vanderbilt today they were the richest  people in the world what happened to  them why does it disappear our research  team went and spent hours  to find out which families did it right  where the wealth keeps passing down for  Generation after generation and which of  them didn't do it right with principles  that they have what values that they  have and we created a webinar for it  which I'm holding specifically for  generational wealth if you want to come  join us it's going to be full very very  quickly click on a link above or below  and I'll see you there